All right. We are taking calls for a one of
the last times at 2019. The phone number is
of course six 1783604750.
Let's go next to our caller from the three
one seven area code. Who's calling today from
three one seven three one seven. I heard you
click on there. Yeah, there you are.
Hi there. Um, my question is, um, um, I've
heard you talk about Trump not likely being
impeached, uh, due to the, uh, Republicans
just smacking it down in the Senate. Uh, do
you think he has a real shot at being present
despite going back on all of his campaign
promises and using ice the way he is allowing
children to die in custody? Like how will
that not destroy him in the upcoming election?
Like what are your thoughts on that?
Because his vote, his supporters either don't
care or don't believe it or think that it's
the fault of Democrats or fill in the blank.
So yeah, I so Trump will, I don't believe
Trump will be convicted by the Senate on impeachment.
Um, I do unfortunately think that unless we
really get turnout up and really do what is
going to be very hard work as a, as a general
rule, it's hard to knock off an incumbent
president. It's particularly difficult when
you have one with a cult of personality around
them. The cult of personality around George
W. Bush was nothing compared to the cult of
personality around Donald Trump. So I F I,
I agree with you. How could someone vote for
this? I understand your frustration. I hear
the frustration in your voice, but unfortunately,
I think that Trump is likely to lose the popular
vote, but he very well may win the electoral
college again and get reelected to another
four years and it will be horrible.
Oh my gosh. Well that was the, a question.
Well, that was the answer I was hoping not
to get, but I, I appreciate that. It seems
like the situation that we're in, but um,
but listen, it's not a foregone conclusion,
right? I mean, that's the thing we've got
to, we, it's up to us. It's, we've half the
country doesn't vote. If people go out and
vote, it's very easy. We don't even really
have to convince anyone to change their mind
about Trump. We just have to make sure that
the people that normally don't vote and might
not otherwise vote, go out and vote and then
we win. It's just easier said than done.
Right. Right. Well, I'll be,
uh, I'll be looking forward to it for sure.
All right. Thank you so much for the call.
Very much appreciate hearing from you